um
thought i would start with that just to
get your attention that was yesterday
working out of my gym while listening to
korean
today was a lower uh level of activity
type of day
i went to a chosen ilbo and imported a
couple of articles
into link which i've read and linked
uh played hockey we lost badly
uh i had lunch with uh three old friends
that joined the canadian government
trade commissioner service together with
me back in 1967.
so we've known each other for a long
long time
then i went to the office for three four
hours so then i came home i was a bit
tired i had a bit of a nap
then i went then we had dinner and then
i went to watch my grandson play hockey
and i'm back so really i haven't done
much today oh the other thing is i had a
conversation at six o'clock with a tutor
by skype on link
uh i was gonna record it webcam but the
recording was kind of messed up so i
will do one
the next time i do one of those it sure
pointed out the gaps in my korean
just a quick comment here uh it'll be a
short video today
people often ask me why do you bother
what motivates you to learn languages
and uh you know um
reading the korean newspaper
uh it was a an editorial
um listening to
you know what people in korea at least
some people have to say
you know every country every people have
things to say they say it in their way
when you hear it in their language it
just has
more resonance it vibrates more if you
read it in an english translation it's
just not the same i like to hear what
different people have to say in their
language russian czech chinese korean
french spanish
romanian
you just get a different flavor it's
it's just
you know we're here on this world and we
we share this world with these different
cultures and and languages and to be
able to participate is just tremendously
rewarding
also i must say i felt somewhat the same
i was driving home from my grandson's
hockey game
and i had this uh i was listening to
music in my car uh and it happened to be
a thing on my iphone that's that was
shuffling so i heard triolos paraguayos
so i'm listening to
paraguay
then
i think was
fran's list so here i am
participating sharing
in something that was
written
by this wonderful man who lived in the
in the 19th century and who is
german hungarian lived in france
it was a wonderful pianist who
who
and then a composer and who donated
donated many of his earnings to good
causes and and i'm able to share in that
so to the extent that we can share
across
geography across
language barriers into different
centuries that's part of why i'm
interested in history
all of that relates to language and so i
derive tremendous enjoyment but there's
a fair amount of work to be done up
front to learn the language
someone also asked me you know how do
you get motivated to stay with it every
day normally i don't if it weren't for
the 90 day challenge i wouldn't be
pushing myself so hard to do something
every day i have to admit that when i
was studying russian or even czech days
would go by when i wouldn't do anything
then i'd get keen for a while i'd listen
in the car somewhat passively here with
my 90-day challenge i'm determined to do
better than that so i'm going to be
stepping up my speaking
and be working hard
and that's it for today
bye for now